so YouTube celebrity culture is a topic
that seems to have been talked about
near to death on this website recently
and with good reason - it is very
important personally I didn't want to
jump in unless I felt like I had
something new and valuable to add to the
conversation but I think I finally think
I do I think I finally think I do there
are a lots of worthy videos surrounding
this topic and so what I'll do is I'll
make a playlist of some of my favorites
and link to that at the end would you
want to watch some more but there was
one video in particular that I saw
yesterday that really struck a chord
with me is by youtuber called Vicky the
pixie and everything that I have to say
today is directly inspired by her video
the bulk of the conversation so far
about YouTube celebrity culture has
surrounded this idea of the ever
widening gap between big famous YouTube
stars and their fans where previously I
used to be pretty uncomfortable with the
idea of referring to big youtubers as
YouTube celebrities nowadays I don't
even bother adding the YouTube to the
beginning of that phrase these people
appear on magazine covers they're on the
sides of buses they get stopped in the
street they can draw crowds of thousands
of people in my mind the biggest of the
big youtubers are just celebrities now
and while I have to assume that a lot of
these now celebrities feel very happy
being just that maybe it was what they
were always hoping for when they start
out not everybody who has that
popularity feels as comfortable with
being screamed at when you walk into a
room can be terrifying for some people
being told that you're somebody's Idol
and that they look up to you as a
perfect example of humanity when you
know that there are many flawed sides to
you that you're not showing them for
some people can be very worrying the big
youtubers on this side of things I think
they don't want to feel other they don't
want to feel special they want to feel
normal they want you to see them as
human beings they don't want you to
idolize them they want you to imagine
them complexly and I do genuinely think
that is all good advice I know that
point of view very well because I've
been there many times myself
and I think it also shows those people
who are giving that advice are taking
their positions as role models very
seriously and that's also a good thing
but and there is a but and it's a very
big buts and I'm going to touch that but
now we've talked nice and loud now about
our big youtuber problems and apparently
we have decided as a group that you are
going to be the ones to fix our problems
for us it's your job now to think more
about us to imagine us more
complexly because we're people too you
know and we're forgetting that this gap
that exists that we're trying to close
exists between two groups of people
because we're treating it I think in a
very one-sided way what Vicky talked
about in her video and that I agree with
is that some big youtubers not all but
some have just as much of an issue
imagining their audiences complexly as
some members of their audience have
imagining them complexly and I believe
this
not as a hunch but because when I've
spent time with some big youtubers in
the past and they decide to tell stories
about their fans the only stories they
seem to want to tell those about their
crazy fans or their stupid fan and I
don't even know if I can remember a time
when I've heard those same youtubers
talk about their experiences with their
friendly fans or their considerate fans
or they're intelligent fans because I
think they have a hard time remembering
that those people exist and I wish that
I could attest to being a perfect
example on the other side of that coin
but I can't because let's be fair it's
hard enough to imagine one person
complexly let alone hundreds of
thousands of people or millions of
people but at the same time I don't
think that means that we shouldn't try
maybe there is something different about
the people who I've met who watch my
videos because I've always felt very
proud to have a group of people who
support my work who are so considerate
and respectful and intelligent and
friendly but my guess is that my
audience isn't unique in that respect
and that most people who want to YouTube
are like that there are always going to
be those individuals that I mean who do
seem to see me as being something
otherworldly but the assumption that I
think is right to make is that you
already know that you're not watching a
person right now that this is a YouTube
video that I have written and performed
it edited and uploaded for your
enjoyment you don't need me to tell you
that because I believe you are smart
enough to figure that out for yourself
and so that is what I would like to
offer as a potential first step towards
closing this gap is that I believe we
need some more respect on both sides
hopefully that wasn't too mean thanks
for watching you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
ok gang you know the drill here's my
most recent video in case you missed it
here's the playlist that I mentioned
starting with the video from Vicky and
I'm not going to try and say anything
funny
right now because it doesn't feel
appropriate for some reason goodbye
you